before we get to the act your age tour
on its way to canada um all the other
little nooks and crannies i want to get
into i know how good of a and everyone
knows how good of a comedian cedric the
entertainer is but how good of a wedding
officiator is he
oh man he made that very memorable
he was amazing and he was so funny
and uh you know there was lots of
moments where i was
on the verge of crying
happy tears obviously but it was a very
emotional moment for me and
so with him doing his little
cedric isms
it spared me
spared the waterworks a little bit
wha uh are there i mean having talked to
your guests made before after the fact
are there any sort of like expectations
of what a wedding is going to look like
when it features a room full of
comedians
well there weren't that many comedians i
don't think there was only a few a few a
handful maybe but there was a lot of
rappers and fighters and djs and
producers you're speaking about you're
speaking my language more and more
oh yeah so you know um
you know that was the fun part for me
let's talk about the wedding obviously
uh you and ali peters
had a wonderful ceremony earlier this
year what is your what was your favorite
part of the wedding outside of the
obvious outside the union like what's
the best part about that ceremony i
think the best part was for the first
time in my life
everything ran on time
ceremony was supposed to start at 3 30
it started right at 3 30. it was
supposed to be over by four it was over
by four
we were going to enter the uh
you know after that it was like drinks
and cocktail hour for people and we did
our photographs and then we were going
to enter the hall at uh six we entered
the hall right at six
the band was going to go on at 7 15. the
band went on at 7 30 which really
bothered me because i was like why are
we behind and uh but it ran smoothly and
every single person that was there said
the same thing this was like this is the
best wedding we've ever been to
the ceremony was quick and funny
and the the dinner was great and there
was only two speeches there was my my uh
my sister-in-law spoke um my wife's
sister and then my brother spoke and
that was it we didn't allow anybody to
get up and i remember one time
and so it was nice and easy
and my daughter wore a dress for me she
didn't want to wear a dress and she
looked really cute and pretty and uh she
was like doing one word i was like she
wore it for me because it's your day
daddy i'll wear a dress and i said okay
thank you baby
uh before we move on to the tour i know
you mentioned cedric sort of helping you
hold back those tears is that you know
as someone who spends their living
on stage making people laugh you know
sometimes being self-depressed
deprecating what what is it like for you
to sort of be a little bit more
um
human open and human and yeah in that
moment because you know i imagine that's
something that a lot of people maybe get
stressed about going into their own
weddings
well i mean there was it was a
highly emotional for me because i was so
happy you know what i mean and it was i
find you know the older you get the
easier you can cry i find
good but it's interesting because like
death doesn't make me cry very much
anymore
death for me is like it's to be expected
um but happy moments make me cry you're
bringing your acura age tour world tour
to canada after four years what's how
good does it feel to be able to bring
this tour now back into the home country
and go everywhere from vancouver all the
way to toronto and beyond
oh well listen coming home is always
exciting for me but coming home with an
act that i'm really really proud of this
time
like this is one of those ones where i'm
like i
i mean i i say i'm proud of it i'm proud
of every act i write but this one is
different in that uh
i didn't struggle to write it
i didn't struggle to write it i didn't
struggle to find the funny in it it just
literally happened and it's so organic
this act
and uh
it's a slight departure from the things
i was talking about
before but at the same time a lot the
most common thing i hear is like
most common uh response i hear to this
act from people is uh
he's back he's like on that
he's like it's like old school russell
out there and i'm like okay that's good
to know i guess i'm happy with that you
know what i mean there was i guess there
was a phase where i went through i was a
little unhappy i was you know and you
could tell when i'm on stage there was a
little
there was an underlying unhappiness
about me
that's gone
beautiful dude is there anything you can
kind of point to for why the the pros
creative process for this
project came together so smoothly and
why you're so happy i mean i'm sure
you're happy with the product but yeah
there's something kind of i mean the
process was you know my process is
always the same process i get on stage
and i talk
and i just started ranting
about
getting older and
and young people and then i started
investigating it on stage like all right
well i say this about young people why
do i say this about young people and
then i realize oh wait that's what
people said about my generation and i
realize you know every generation goes
to the exact same thing
you know every generation thinks the
generation below them are a bunch of
idiots
but no generation takes the blame for it
and i'm here to let the millennials the
gen z's know that as much as we don't
like you
it's my generation's fault that we don't
like you
and i talk about them everything we
don't like about this generation is my
generation's fault every single thing
well i appreciate it russell you know
what hopefully this can be uh the
beginning of reconciliation i'd love for
you and i just sort of
represented for generations there yeah
um you know command i try to stay away
from the internet as much as work will
allow me to and it just really feels
like comedians are being put under the
microscope online these days what do you
think people need to understand about
the role of comedy in society that maybe
they've forgotten over these last
several years
well here's the thing um like here's
what i always say about comedians
uh
comedians are up there to tell the truth
and the truth is like poetry and nobody
likes poetry
it reminds me of my one friend who likes
poetry and he's the most depressing
person i know yeah who like hillary says
i read some great poetry today shut up
what sort of impact do you think that
this sort of current societal debate
about stand-up comedy is going to have
on the next generation of performers
well i talk about that in my new act so
i don't really want to answer that but
because i can see the show guys you got
to come see the show because i really do
tackle all these questions that people
have in there and that they're the
proverbial questions that are being
asked right now
um we often talk about sort of the
artists that inspire us who are some of
the active comedians who inspire you
right now and why
i mean there's so many
there's so many comics out there now
there's so many guys at the top of their
game right now there's so many guys
coming up that are there's a lot of
young comics that i see that make me go
oh okay i gotta i gotta put put my foot
on the gas a little bit you know
sometimes when you're an older comic guy
i'm an older comic now i'm 33 years in
the game so i'm yeah i'm one of the
older comics
and uh uh you know you sometimes you
take your foot off the gas and you coast
then you realize oh
these guys are gaining them i got to put
my foot back on the gas so
there's a lot of cats out there that
write really good jokes really
thought-provoking material well-written
well-rounded and it makes you go
all right i see what i'm i see what i'm
not doing let me get back to focus